alfie stock um if you were with us
earlier you'll uh have heard me quote
his dad saying they've lost everything
um healthy hello
how are you doing
well being considered not too bad you
know tell me what happened
it was
literally all started from a grass pile
next door my brother come in and said i
think i could smell smoke
looked over and it was
not even a fire at that point it was
just just smoldering embers
and um by the time we got round with the
hose pipes it turned into something a
lot bigger than that you know um
within
i'd say about two minutes it would
spread to the house
uh we tried our best to try and dampen
it down on our side to hope it hopes it
would stop spreading you know
um
but obviously you see yourself it it it
didn't stop spreading you know
um
the fire brigade i said they were way
laid elsewhere because there were so
many fires around yesterday
it didn't well turn up you know but i
think even if they turned up immediately
it was it was such a blaze i don't think
they could have done much about it
they're on on the spot you know
um
yeah
i think
i can't i'm looking because first i've
seen the damage today and there's so
many houses they've gone i couldn't
believe i don't know if i'd ever see
anything like this you know
for something so small to within 10
minutes it being well it's our stuff
really
um
yeah but
everyone got out all right which is the
main thing i don't think anyone i don't
mean i've been injured i think all the
neighbors about all their pets put out
fine
um it's just it's just stuff i've just
lost everything you know only talk to me
as much or as little as you want to
obviously i don't want to cause you
anything no no no
so the fire started you tried to put it
out then what happened
um
that's when we phoned the fire brigade
and they turned up and um
they tried their best but because they
was using the water elsewhere
the water pressure was so low
it wasn't touching it wasn't even
reaching the roof
um so within five minutes they said that
our house it couldn't be saved so that's
when we moved out tried to grab a few
bits from the shed because obviously
everything in the house was lost um but
we didn't grab much you know just a few
bits just a few memories you know
and um
i thought that was it i thought it was
just contained in ours and when i come
round to the front the green i saw it
obviously
the field had gone up the trees right
down ken view the the street adjacent to
it had completely gone out i just it was
absolute carnage you know
um yeah just a real shock when did you
realize that you needed to leave the
house
um immediately i think we all left the
actual house itself no one wants to go
back in because
we could see the damage to the
neighbor's house which is obviously
joined to it and i thought it could come
down you know so it was quite sensible
in that sense no one wants to rush back
in for anything like we left everything
we just left it we got dog out that was
the main thing
and then um
when
we moved to the garden we've got quite a
big yard at the end
um we managed to get some stuff out of
the shed so we waited down there because
we thought we'd be safe there but then
we saw the garden come down the shed
come down and it started moving out that
way
so we had to pop the fence into the fire
station which is just behind
we waited there and then that set on
fire so we had to move from there again
it was just constantly out running all
day
i want you just to clarify when you were
saying how it started it was just a pile
of cutting yeah yeah you know how like
compost um compost tv heats up infinite
yeah like we had it before in your
garden in the next garden um he's in
hospital at the moment so no one was in
um has he lost his hair oh yes hopefully
thank god no one was in there you know
um
i mean we had it about 10 years ago that
bird like grass pile went up and a tree
burnt and that was it before we came
around it was fine but
i've never even dreamed it could turn
into something like this you know what
about your neighbors how did you start
to alert them about what was going on
i think the um
because i think quite a few people out
in the gardens because of the heat
obviously
so i think a lot of people saw the smoke
immediately but there was quite a few
elderly people that um obviously were
indoors and upstairs and stuff so we
just said everyone who'd come out we
just said go knock as many doors as you
can
and i think everyone got involved you
know everyone was coming their houses
they weren't going back for their stuff
they was making sure that everyone else
was getting out you know
it just uh it was it was lovely to see
really it was
circumstances how many houses do you
think have been lost i've
i think i heard that 10 maybe have
actually burned down because the fire
spread to ken view and it it ripped
through the roof you know it went
through the lofts
but um
i can't imagine the amount of
uninhabitable because of smoke damage it
was it was so thick um obviously there's
it's a lot of damage it's a lot of
damage how are your mum and dad
devastated they're they're trying to put
on a brave face i think everyone is you
know but um i think sitting on the news
last night it zoomed right in on where
our house used to be seeing it fall down
you know
i mean they've lived there all their
life and my dad grew up there um
it's a big loss but um i think they just
keep reminding themselves that everyone
got out safe
the dog's fine i think that's what i
think mum was worried about um family's
all right
so it's all you can ask for where did
you go what happened
um we went to uh chatham sports centre
which is paris academy now sorry um
and first of all there was no one in
there we thought i would just get a bit
of shelter but then so many people
started coming around from all different
areas dropping bags of stuff off there
was food water
clothes um someone bought my mum on the
phone she left everything um it was i
couldn't believe it the the
overwhelming kindness it was it was a
bit much to be honest you know but um
yeah people give us a lift people drove
us smiles like picking our stuff up and
that just like at the kind of story i
couldn't believe it really couldn't
believe it and what now
that you'll guess as good as mine um
i was hoping we could maybe get down
closer but the road shut off uh suppose
we can get today
um
just sorting out all the bank stuff in
that now sort out all the documents are
being lost trying insurance and things
and stuff you've got insurance uh yeah
there was house insurance so uh
there are some things that are
replaceable but
most of it is you know especially with
maxwell
you